harder you're stronger than nice Diane
again
[Music]
never let your guard down you expect a
battle to be fair about the will never
be fair
my name is Captain Steve Trevor pilot
American Expeditionary Forces serial
number eight one four one nine two one
that's all I'm at liberty to assign the
British intelligence what the hell is
this thing the LA Zoo of Hestia compels
you to reveal the truth is really hard
what is your mission whoever you are you
are in more danger than you think what
is your mission
I am spy I miss by
um yep that's not gonna work
please put the sword down Lana dinah let
me try it by myself after you sir
better why don't I meet you back at the
office and meanwhile I'll take this for
safety oh no I don't think you gotta put
the sword down Diana please it doesn't
go with the outfit at all
put the sword down first of all promise
me it won't protect it with your life
yes no you can trust her just hand that
over she owes and the shield well you
got it thanks setup is easy
Steve why are we hiding
captain Trevor I believe you have
something that is the property of
general ludendorf that's the bad guy
convention give us dr. Marr was notebook
alright let that thing
or maybe not
tough luck is there anything else you
want to show me
[Music]
stay here I'll go ahead
[Music]
with the surprise stretch
unfortunately I have another matter to
attend to
what you will soon find out
[Music]
as magnificent as you are you are still
no match for me we'll see about that
please slow down your leader how could
he say that believes that you with your
duty to simply give them a book you
didn't offend your Browns you didn't
fight because there was no chance of
changing his way Harry and he's not
going to allow a negotiation or a
surrender the millions of people he
talks about they will die we're going
anyway you mean you were lying I'm a spy
that's what I do how do I know you're
not lying to me right now I am taking
you to the front where didn't need
reinforcements
[Applause]
dianna fighting does not make you a
human what if I promise to be careful
just a shield and iron no sharp edges be
careful with mankind Diana
they do not deserve you you've told me
this story
[Music]
what is this place who are you people we
are the bridge to a greater
understanding right what is your mission
well here's the thing you are in more
danger than you think the boys in the
trenches called her doctor poison my
millions would die the war would never
end
I'm going mother if you choose to leave
you may never return how will I be if I
stay
so the Lord well technically the wars
that way but we got to go this way first
how can a woman fighting this who's this
young woman
she's my
and Diana Princess of Timnath Prince
Diana Prince
[Music]
if you believe that this war should stop
help me stop it right now
it will soon find out
[Music]
[Music]
Wonder Woman where the pg-13 experience
at an IMAX 3d June 2nd if you never met
a man before what about your father I
had no father I was brought to life by
Zeus
[Music]
what is your mission
to stop the war
the war to end all wars
no one else will defend the world than I
must
oh that's neat
be careful Diana
welcome to jolly old London
he is yeah it's not for everybody
I really like her
[Music]
step back tough luck
[Music]
who's this woman you'll soon find out
Wonder Woman is there anything else you
want to show me
[Music]
only in cinemas
you